in Wake of this game to defeat at the
hands of the Lakers was Dylan Brooks
embracing the villainous role saying
LeBron is old I don't respect anyone
until they hang 40 on me here's what the
residual looked like just a few moments
ago during pregame warm-ups LeBron
walking over to Brooks having a very
I would say characterize it as a low-key
conversation Doris until I saw this
pregame I thought that conversation
between them was a whole lot about
nothing but you know the expression from
the old show the liar if you come for
the king you best not miss this guy has
the gravitas in the game to back up
whatever he just said also